Trendy Wellington is dubbed the "Capital of Cool."
It's as if the fresh ocean winds bring in waves of creativity.
Home to less than half a million people,...
...Wellington isn't New Zealand's most populous city,...
...but it is the country's political, cultural and culinary capital.
Imaginative street art, vintage shops, a hip cafe culture, incredible scenery,...
...splendid museums and a touch of tradition make Wellington a breath of fresh air.
Journey south to experience Wellington's legendary hospitality,...
...clean air and quality of life.
Whichever page you turn in New Zealand's distant capital,...
...you'll discover that magic and adventure is just around the corner.